j'ai en tout cas vous annoncer j'ai
rencontré la femme de ma vie va ajuster
et
[Musique]
cette offensive
et toi tu l'as remplaçant moins de deux
par un objet transitionnel non c'est pas
un objet transitionnel c'est cécile ok
elle s'appelle cécile touchés par ces
partis pour un tour
[Musique]
gladys magali samira je sais tout est
cool tu sais prison la tâche est quoi
vous moi je cuis envie de raconter une
histoire risque pas d'arriver je dit se
sentir vraiment pareil
j'adore rester chez moi poser tranquille
[Applaudissements]
alors tu la belle cécile planting
cantine cécile les ex je sors jamais
avec alain le dire tu as l'air d'en
avoir tellement que ce serait coupée
quelques choisir nymphomane je ne nie
pas aucune provocation ma chérie
[Musique]
c'est un peut embrasser mes savons pas
qui a pas pénétration ça compte pas il
ya deux écoles
t'inquiète pas ça me regarde pas
soixante pardon pour moi j'ai pu en tout
cas je l'avais jamais fait ça là encore
la wii balance café tu vois je fais des
efforts j'ai de changer bien fait pour
sa gueule juste été un peu maladroite et
juste rester toi même en fait
c'est hyper beau ce que tu as fait pour
elle il ya quelques mois tu aurais été
incapable de faire un truc pareil à
tétouan confiance à cherré comme moi je
te fais confiance
[Musique]
de retour ce cil dont 137 heures